- Die tote Oma?
- Ja, das Gericht „Tiegelwurst“
hatten wir so genannt.
Das ist umgangssprachlich.
- Ja, Nico hatte das aber wörtlich genommen.
Er ist nicht aus Deutschland.
- Es tut mir leid! Ich war ängstlich.
Ich dachte, Oma Inge wäre
wirklich etwas passiert.
- Du bist herrlich, Nico!
- Ja, das alles ist uns
wirklich sehr peinlich.
Wir bedauern sehr,
dass Sie kommen mussten.
- Aber das war keine böse Absicht!
- Nein. Das hätte jedem passieren können.
Also jedem, der die Sprache nicht kennt.
- Eigentlich sollten wir Nico dankbar sein.
Er hat Zivilcourage bewiesen!
Er hatte sich Sorgen gemacht.
- Genau! Eigentlich ist es
gar nicht peinlich,
wenn jemand es gut meint!
- Sollen wir uns denn Ihren Hals
mal anschauen, junge Frau?
Wenn wir schon einmal hier sind …
- Junge Frau, Sie machen mich
ganz verlegen.
Mir geht's gut!
- Dann einen schönen Tag noch!
- Ah, danke! Ihnen auch!
- Dankeschön!
- Schönen Tag noch!
- Wiedersehen!
- Ich mach‘s schon …